check this out
a nightmare scenario you find out that
your friends are talking behind your
back an even bigger nightmare you find
out through a viral video on tick-tock
watch this
i hate to be the one to stick my nose
where it doesn't belong but if your
name's marissa please listen up
i just walked by your friends and i need
to tell you that the weekend you're away
is not the only time that they could do
their birthday party
they are choosing to do it the weekend
year away and you need to know tick tock
help me find marissa
okay well he actually found marissa and
her name is marissa mize and
these people were in fact her friends
this became a giant new york times
story they were conspiring against her
but this was just the start of a much
more epic story marissa said goodbye to
fake friends and started a nationwide
movement that was even featured in the
new york times which i just showed you
and she's here exclusively to tell us
about it please welcome marissa maize
[Applause]
i am going to be super honest i'm star
struck by you i have been so excited
[Applause]
okay i feel the same way about you so
we're on the same page it's all right
like your story has everything that kind
of is the meaning of life for me wrapped
up in one beautiful burrito and i have
to ask you like
what was as a human being your first
reaction when you saw that tick tock
video and how it found its way to you
yeah i think when i when i first saw the
video i got it sent to me by so many
different people and i watched the video
originally and it was that kind of like
gut feeling that there was so many
details in the video that just added up
too much that was
very specific to me and so after that i
posted a video back saying hey i think
this is about me and i
don't know what to do you know and
overnight i gained a hundred thousand
followers i got thousands and thousands
of messages from people
all around the world
and um i think that's when it kind of
just hit me into how how much people
were relating about this so you took
your lemons and you made the biggest
picture of lemonade ever
tell us what you did next yeah since i
received so many of those messages from
just so many people
from all over of saying you know let's
be friends forget your old friends you
know what do you what do i take from
that and that's when i decided to have
the first meet-up in central park and
that's when no more lonely friends was
born so
[Applause]
you started with one meet-up um but it
turned into
literally the epitome of a movement
how do you think it grew so fast um i
posted one video from the first original
meetup and that went viral as well and
people were like come to my city i want
this in my city i i want friends in my
city this has happened to me and that's
when i started doing
los angeles san francisco boston philly
dc uh this past weekend was nashville
raleigh i mean and there's so many more
until the end of this year how cool is
that
yeah
it's really cool
all the layers in this story and it just
shows you like also it doesn't go to
like a mean girl's place of like yeah
screw those friends it's like actually
we should all avoid toxic friendships
and let's meet up and fight for it and
find it and get it and seek it out and
we actually have someone in the audience
who went to a meetup sylvia
thank you uh for showing up today and uh
being able to give us a first-hand kind
of account of what this has brought to
your life
well um i followed marissa from the
beginning and so um i was like i have to
go even though i have anxiety and i was
scared to go i went anyway
so but i got there and um i saw my wrist
right away she gave me a big hug and
then she introduced me to some other
people we all sat down they offered me
their blankets they offered me food they
offered me water we all just started
talking it was just like a lot of light
and positivity
and um it was just a great experience
overall the ages didn't matter i'm 53.
everybody was so loving and marissa i
just want to tell you it only takes one
person in this world to make a
difference and you are that one person
that's true making me cry here man
good
you deserve to feel all those feelings
and i can't thank you enough i mean
when i hoped you would share your
experience i could have never hoped it
would be so personal and eloquent and
powerful thank you and it brought tears
to my eyes um
we all need each other yeah and we
actually have a few other people
here who you have inspired um there's 55
people here um will you guys stand up
oh
[Applause]
because of you and because of the
beautiful organization and movement you
have started no more lonely friends i
love you guys thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you so much
[Music]
you